how do you feel about the tour's
expansion this year with more continents
more players and more money
I think certainly having more events as
good it means that there are going to be
more more chess players so they're gonna
there's gonna be more variety across the
board in terms of styles and sort of
personalities so I think that having
more players makes it interesting having
more events as well as sort of
legitimate legitimizes the tour and I
think because of that it just it it
makes it it makes it a great great event
and I think with all the top players
competing I know lash are one there were
a couple people who didn't didn't
compete one in particular but just it's
just it's just great to see that you are
expanding more events more prize money
and I think for the world of chess it's
a very very much a good thing well I'm
very pleased obviously as a professional
player it's great news for me because
just a few years ago before the grand
gesture
it's very difficult for players to have
a serious calendar and tournament just
come and go I was always hoping that you
know it's didn't - it was not restricted
to restrictive in terms of players so
it's a good start
for the first of Mobb players of course
a very good thing to have more events or
one the world I'll be skipping India's
this year but I'm sure there will be
other opportunities for me to to come
there
it's very important that now it looks
like there is some good good
collaboration between freedom and
Grantchester because in the past there
were some problems and it's very good
for chess because you know back like 20
or 30 years ago when people are
criticizing casparo for organizing some
alternative or Federation's or
organizations I don't think it was bad
for players definitely it is great for
players there were more events and
that's what we will actually want to ask
for you know so the more events there
are the better it is for us so it's
really really good well I believe that
it's very good for sheltered the
Grantchester is growing up and it's not
standing on on one level is getting up
and up and getting stronger and stronger
and for me for the professionals just
where it is very important I'm
definitely all for it I'm looking
forward to playing 11 games instead of
nine and new classical events yeah the
more the merrier so I very much water
you